[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen meine torten
welt heute starte ich endlich mit meinem
herbst special was ich euch schon lange
vorher angekündigt hatte hatte die
möglichkeit mehr rezept wünsche zu
schicken oder bzw bei facebook als
kommentar zu posten und die habe ich
berücksichtigt haben jetzt ein paar
rezepte für euch zusammengestellt und
welche ihr euch jetzt jeden tag als
video eben vorstellen heute möchte ich
mit meinem lieblingsrezept starten das
ist der april kuren und zwar ist das ein
ganz normaler rührteig um etwas festere
rührteig da kommen dann die äpfel drauf
und da kommen die wirklich leckersten
sträuße die ich eigentlich kennen und
die streusel schmecken einfach so lecker
weil ich wann sie mit einarbeiten
ihr könnt natürlich auch andere nüsse
benutzen bevor es allerdings zum
rührteig geht möchte ich erst mal zeigen
was man mit den äpfeln macht und zeigt
euch dann wie es weitergeht
ich habe jetzt hier sechs äpfel das sind
etwa 650 gramm und ich hab die sorte
elster ihr könnt aber auch ganz gut
boskop nehmen und ihr braucht eine halbe
zitrone und wer möchte noch etwas zimt
die äpfel müssen jetzt noch geschält und
geschnitten werden und es können nur mit
einem ganz normalen sparschäler machen
ich mache das jetzt einfach mit so einem
apfel schneider und zwar ich weiß nicht
wo daher ist dann habe ich geschenkt
bekommen
das erspart mir ziemlich viel arbeit
weil ich so in einem schritt den apfel
schälen und schneiden kann also der wert
so spiralförmig geschnitten und zeigt
euch das mal
so die schale kann man einfach wegnehmen
und das hier unternehmen und dann hat
man praktisch den geschälten apfel in so
einer spirale geschnitten und das innere
kann man da nur unternehmen und gab es
somit an äpfel machen und die äpfel
müssen danach klein geschnitten werden
die die ich jetzt so schon so als
spirale hat bei denen ist es natürlich
schwierig da halte ich den april und
schreit hier einfach ein paar stücke
runter und habe ihr dann kleine scheiben
und bei dem ganzen apfel einfach früher
halbieren und in stücke teilen und steht
dann ganz einfach in scheiben schneiden
und wenn ihr es dann soweit habt kommt
dann noch die zitrone mit rein so
ungefähr eine halbe und werke eine zimt
mag so wie ich da gibt jetzt hier noch
etwas zimt mit rein so etwas halten
teelöffel bis 1 teelöffel und dann wird
es einmal durchgeführt und komplette
lang stehen lassen bis ihr den teig
vorbereitet habt die apple werden jetzt
auch nicht frauen dadurch dass eben die
zitrone jetzt mit rein gemacht
für den teig braucht ihr 125 gramm
weiche butter 100 gramm zucker eine
packung vanillezucker oder einen
esslöffel vanillezucker und eine prise
salz ist da noch mit dabei ihr braucht
drei eier 200 gramm mehl 2 teelöffel
backpulver und eventuell noch ein schuss
milch davon so etwa 1 2 esslöffel zuerst
geht dir jetzt die weiche butter in
einer rührschüssel und die wird da mit
dem zucker dem vanillezucker und der
präses hans weiss kriege nicht geworden
das dauert so etwa 23
[Musik]
und danach gibt ihr nach und nach die
eier mit rein und lassen es richtig
schön weiter rühren
[Musik]
und dann kommen da einfach die anderen
zutaten mit rein angst noch das nähe und
das backpulver dann gebe ich erst mal
nur einen schluck milch mit rein
es kommt immer darauf an wie groß sind
[Musik]
ich habe zehn richtig schönen glatten
früher teig und von der konsistenz her
ist das so wirklich gut er sollte nicht
zu flüssig sein aber auch nicht zu fest
und dann gebt ihr den teig einfach in
eure vorbereitete springform und
streicht den dann richtig schön glatt
und da kommen jetzt noch die äpfel mit
drauf und deswegen darf der teig auch
nicht flüssig sein
die äpfel sollen den strom fliegen und
nicht in den stein brauchen und dann
einmal schön verteilen
das riecht richtig schön herzlich mit
den äpfeln
jetzt stelle ich das gerade mal kurz zur
seite und bereit noch die wahllos
streusel vor
und dann geht es in den ofen für die
streusel braucht ihr jetzt 60 gramm
weiche butter 60 gramm zucker 70 gramm
walnüsse falls ihr keine wahl gehabt
oder keine mögt ihr auch haselnüsse oder
mandeln nehmen und 75 gramm mehl und das
ganze wird noch mit einem halben
teelöffel zimt verfeinert
meine wahl müsste die strecke jetzt in
der tüte und werte etwas kleiner
ihr könnt sie auch gemahlen kaufen ich
möchte sie aber etwas fertig haben und
deswegen rollig damit kosten und dann
habe das ist schön klein aber eben auch
probe stückchen mit dabei und hier geht
es ganz schnell ich benutzt einfach die
schüssel in der ich auch meinen teig
vorbereitet habe da gebe ich jetzt
einfach alle zutaten rein und lässt er
dann verrühren bis eben eine streusel
masse entstanden ist
[Musik]
so sollte das dann in etwa aussehen und
dann kommt es hier einfach auf die erste
[Musik]
und wer möchte könnte jetzt hier zum
beispiel noch ein paar walnuss hälften
mit reinlegen einfach so zur dekoration
und so wird das ganze 2 175 grad ober
und unterhitze etwa 40 minuten gebacken
ihr müsst darauf achten dass die
streusel nicht so dunkel werden
ansonsten werden sie etwas bitter und
dann zeige ich euch an das endergebnis
so sieht der kuchen jetzt ausländer aus
dem ofen raus ist und ich habe jetzt
auch eine stäbchen probe gemacht das
können ja auch machen einfach hier
eingestochen
und dann war da nichts mehr dran
natürlich ist der zahnstocher etwas
feucht durch die feuchten äpfel aber es
hängt eben kein tag mehr dran denen dass
ich jetzt so auskühlen setzen dann auf
eine tortenplatte und dann ist der
kuchen auch schon fertig wer möchte kann
den dann natürlich auch mit etwas
puderzucker bestäuben
aber da schmeckt auch sicherlich so ganz
gut ich hoffe dieses rezept gefällt euch
und ihr probiert diesen leckeren
apfelkuchen mal aus morgen wird ein
anderes rezept was kommt möchte ich noch
gar nicht beraten das werdet ihr dann
morgens sehen und ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß mit dieser reihe
falls sie auch mal ne idee habt für so
eine themenwoche könnt ihr mir gerne mal
eine idee geben oder einen vorschlag ich
versucht haben sie irgendwie mit
einzubauen was ich auf jeden fall mal
machen werden ist eine türkische woche
dann gibt es eben eine woche lang jeden
tag typische rezepte da freue ich mich
auch schon frauen und dann sehen wir uns
ja schon morgen wieder bis bald
[Musik]